citizens of the reject Nation I am so
happy you clicked on this video today
because we're gonna watch and or episode
six John how goes it uh it goes It goes
well sir how goes you the force goes
well within Greg today Force ghost thank
you so much for being here leave a like
first order of business second order
first order get it second order thank
you to all who have joined us on our
patreon page because uh your support
means the world to catch a full and
threat watch along is there third order
of business thank you to Tops for
sponsoring this video and introducing us
to Star Wars card Trader so excited to
be working with them because as you
nerds uh like uh no we would love to
collect we all love to collect stuff
there's a lot of ways to collect the
things you love in the way Star Wars car
trader works is it lets you collect your
favorite Star Wars characters weapons
spacecraft more John this is when you
should be showing your phone dude look
you got me a storm
so you can admire it at your collection
from anywhere anytime and then so they
they have keep keep the phone up because
this is a real cool thing a phase they
have a ton of exclusive collectible
content to discover plus you can meet
and trade with other Star Wars fans
across the Galaxy anywhere anytime to
help complete sets and missions earn
Awards and more plus you can even take
the cards you've already gotten combine
them make new and even more rare
collectibles on the workbench it's a
great Star Wars positive community
experiences which is something we
heavily encourage so guys this app is
free to play on IOS and Android so join
us now on Star Wars car trader by tops
Link in description
foreign
here you go liar
I couldn't sleep
struggling to understand why my faith
doesn't calm me I believe in something
why am I so unsettled I mean you have
nothing
so you think it's hopeless do you
Freedom Independence Justice
we should just submit and be thankful
take what we're given you need to get
sleep man do I look thankful to you
no
you'll sleep when it's done
I hope so nemec foreshadowing that he's
gonna die we found the best way to steer
them as we like is to offer alternatives
you put a number of options on the table
and they're so wrapped up in shoes
you've given them nothing they thought
they wanted to the start like my Netflix
account
falling behind
it's getting gorgeous doesn't he
didn't tell you did they
he was a stormtrooper no [ __ ]
should have been doing centerfound
though
they slaughtered our whole family this
guy knows how to give Exposition he's
what Finn should have been the guests
are arriving
will do sir form up don't quietly
peaceful like might be best if we split
these up between us
oh damn it's intense
got a good look at her
patience of course you pieces of crap
would stop right here I was gonna make a
joke that he needed to take a pee
never thought they'd do it
with surround piece on them did you oh
my God look at that dude
Roberta
undressing Leonard he's 12 he can dress
himself I need you to trust me and then
compressed perhaps you've expanded
and door was right they're so fat fat
and satisfied I don't feel well you'll
make an effort tonight if it kills you
he might have a fever you might feel the
back of my head the boy is ill would you
hold
it's always Hill
do they call domestic violence in Star
Wars space domestic violence
yes absolutely because in space domestic
violence no one can hear you scream halt
we gotta we spent my child
Hood
snow Frank
Cranston learned a whole new link for
this show
let's go
I'm not tired at all
tighten up
if you don't bother them
they won't bother you so I want mouths
shut and eyes open
right turn
with me
one wrong marching move to get noticed
Squad
awesome
has she checked in
not yet
problem
she'll be there
this is so tense I love it it's time to
mess up they were supposed to call us
what are you gonna learn we were waiting
you were waiting that's your excuse
me
yes sir
where is she relate
wait oh Kenzie
no they're shutting down right now yikes
solid
Colvin you're sure
you're stalling
call them Jesus God
Valley one Valley one It Go
are you on point
we go
May the eye find the good in all of us
that's not what I said that's done
anything we're close to what I said
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
stop talking stop right there
let the boy go
please
nobody has to die
[Music]
dang you're so hot
you're late you can join your man at the
bottom of the hill now
enjoy the eye
yes sir thank you sir
you'll never get out of here
that was a light slap didn't you hear me
I don't control the Vault it's on a code
from the air base it's done remotely
keep lying and it'll be a short night
for you
how it works we need your hand to key
the sensor
we can take just that if you prefer
you'll never make it out one part one
choice we win or everyone dies
Starts Now
shoot the kid
show him you mean business
that was like a regular gun like a like
a bullet gun yeah if we get what we came
for everyone walks away but if we go
down you're right there with us 14
minutes the show's so brilliant getting
you invested in the family
all right I'll be fine oh my God are
they lovers oh I think they might be
okay hinted at that in a previous
episode
flow coming down inspection let's go
hand on hand
[Music]
this is all going according to plan
right now
they've already killed
homeboy up on the bridge is probably
gonna throw a wrench in all this
oh
in go I'm almost done I'll be right
behind you
guys
it must be the eye
let's go
I was so good at using the geography and
the proximity and ugh
Oh no you're gonna die today
we'll miss the eye
wow that's a great shot
I hope you know how to fly that thing
out if you're Andor
there's so much left
oh my God that's beautiful
it's so real
Mac Miller
[Music]
wow
two minutes
I was afraid you'd be leaving we need to
be locking up
no I did not think he'd reveal himself
you're hanging for this seven years
serving you
I deserve worse than that
nice oh
holy [ __ ] no this is so oh my God I am
in that it's so intense but beautiful
this is an image it's so intense but
beautiful my God what's going on here
time to open fire
oh [ __ ] time to open fire this is a this
is a classified Mission and you're not
clear to be here
open fire tell him he needs to leave
sir I am giving you a direct order
Corporal what is going on here oh
space heart attack we need a space
doctor
just had to be here at Ninja kimzey
no
God it looks so good
instead of throwing a Wilhelm scream on
that oh
oh God damn it
oh nice shot
chills everywhere
so good
chairman oh man
Terrafin
[Music]
[Applause]
better haul assandor
damn
oh no
no
not my dude
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
still what is that Med Spike keep
himself
there's a Chinese get up my legs feel
better
oh my God where's this ride I know come
on Disneyland get your [ __ ] together get
that top rail going
[Music]
wow holy moly
no I don't have the speed to make it now
you want me to climb
climb just do it what are you gonna lose
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wow
[Music]
there might have been a little home
screaming there
that is so beautiful
behold the eye there's a doctor we have
a built into the contingency she doesn't
want to jeopardize the mission space
doctor
this kid is the reason that we are here
this space kid
oh
Cassian heart dork
Robo legs oh what a great doctor
forearms
it's really well done yeah it's like an
anime character or a Men In Black
character or a Star Wars character you
want to guess how much is in there 80
million give or take what'd you tell me
you want to win and walk away 40 million
a piece don't tell me you haven't
thought about it see I can't fly the
trawler but I do have a safe place we
can hole up you can't do a heist movie
without having this character
our Rebellion for you oh I'm a rebel
it's just uh me against everybody else
well that put me 40 million credits is
enough for me to forget all about you
your brother with the orchard I don't
have a brother
I saw the first minute you came into
Camp you're just like me we were born in
the hole and all we know is climbing
over somebody else to get out there's a
moon eight par six from here but nobody
home put that thing down
catch our breath put up the winnings
oh damn how are you going to explain
that he was just testing you Andor and
and you passed it was part of the test
ten
thank you
for trying
what no oh you gotta be kidding me no
man
everyone's just dying Escape he's dead
he wanted to take the money and leave
you here he wouldn't do that you're
gonna have to think about that
you disgusting bastard nemix Manifesto
he said to give this to you
I don't want it
he insisted I don't know major pretty
reactionary when it comes to Traders or
the money so maybe
the right guy ever that Manifesto you
know
and you did stop on his behalf yeah
but what's going on with my Mothman her
husband is he being addictor
is their daughter mouthing off again
the Senate is not what it used to be
big Rebel attack last night it's all the
news maybe we have something in the back
[Music]
I was gonna say jump up and down my man
hahaha
[Music]
wow what a reaction all right ladies and
gentlemen the Rebellion has begun it has
kicked off and after the end of the last
episode when Lutheran was talking with
assistant lady
Michael Sonam Obsession I don't know her
name but after I was talking with her
and then she was like it'll all be over
tomorrow
and he ended up with saying or just
starts and then here this one ends with
getting the wish the Rebellion has begun
he calls him like a rebel attack at
aldani and uh I think that's great
because this whole thing has been this
is there a rise of a rebellion about to
happen they're trying to get kick off
the Rebellion so that's what we get left
with here some great turns at the end of
this episode I actually did not see that
coming at all with uh the character
Skeen
betraying and the team I thought he was
one of the the Loyalists especially when
he went off on Andor in the last episode
like see what's his real agenda here
he's got 30 000 kyber crystals creditors
right here look at look what he has
and then to find out that he was just
willing to run off with them that was it
was a bit of a left field uh for me I
was I was kind of I was kind of shocked
by that and I really believe that whole
speech that he gave about his brother at
the very end and I don't know where
that's going to leave him ultimately
with who is the what's what's the lady's
name and who's leading Ville Vel yeah
with Vel leaving her behind with the
body of nemec who
from the first scene in this episode I
was like okay nemix definitely die like
the way they teased at the very end
the way they tease it at the very
beginning I forget what it was but there
was something that was exchanged at the
top of that scene it was about him
sleeping after the mission's done
sleeping after the mission's done and
yes he gets to actually sleep after this
but him being a revolutionist and
everything that he was writing down in
that book which is called
oh his Manifesto the manifesto that he
has nemix nemix Manifesto
maybe one day they'll release that
journal a little book that you can buy a
little collectible with a nemix
Manifesto being handed off to Andor and
andor's this kind of character that I
think you know I do see it debated as a
matter of fact I as I was loading the
footage for the reaction
um into the into the computer
I I put it on Twitter right away about
how like man really bums me out that
nothing not enough people are watching
this series because I thought this
episode in particular was a wildly tense
taught exciting and some of the most
beautiful imagery that Star Wars has
ever delivered and uh there was a
response in there that I've heard
several times by this point about not
finding Cassie and Andor to be the most
interesting character to really follow
and I kind of get what why people might
say that I personally really enjoy
watching Diego Luna I feel like there's
a lot going on underneath the surface
for this character and I think some of
the times you really get to know the
best is through the actions that he
takes you know while a bit predictable
that he would join this mission
you know being enticed ultimately with
credits you do see at the very end of it
when nemec is injured that they decide
to take a detour to try to save him and
save his life by taking him to the
doctor
and also when skein does reveal his true
colors showing like no let's just split
this money and hide off somewhere else
forget the rest of these guys
that it angers him this level of
betrayal that this guy has
and you can also tell that in times in
conversation with nemec that he is
there's this resistance there's this
resistance that he has towards the
ideals that there is hope
for the people that are not with the
Empire and then perhaps whatever
conversation this Springs or imagery
this Springs this attack on all Donnie
this Rebel attack that might be the
thing that thrusts him to keep going on
with it because especially with Val
leaving off there it's like
you know he he knows he can't convince
her that he did not that that that uh
Skeen
what was in fact a Trader he can't do
the convincing but he did enough actions
of like
look I'm buying I'll give you 30 000
credits to camp out here I just want to
take my money here I'm returning this
give it back to your friend like he's
not trying to get more run off with more
he just wants what he got paid for so
it's like why why would he kill skiing
then like what would be the point of it
so there's enough to to reason that
perhaps he was maybe telling the truth
and also with the emotional investment
Val has anemic that perhaps with nemec
seeing the good in Andor and that
there's something that is stronger in
there to fight for something greater
that might convince her so I'm not sure
where that'll leave them but there has
to be something in conjunction
considering vel's Association and
closeness with luthin
that it has to lead to you know her
coming back around and then bringing
Adriana along
yeah back to it so yeah I thought this
was a great Heist episode and uh
wonderfully composed from beginning to
end it was it was just a really strongly
strongly structured and composed and
just a real very thrilling and just a
wonderful escalation of stakes
throughout yeah I agree I I feel like
I I can also see why somebody would say
like oh you know Android's not that
interesting of a character or whatever I
feel like this show much like how I
experienced Rogue one is like yeah there
are Central characters but it really is
about the situation and it's about an
ensemble and I have a feeling that as
we've seen here most of the Ensemble we
followed for this leg of the mission has
perished but I feel like we will trade
one Ensemble for the next and I don't
think that's necessarily A Bad Thing yes
the show is named after Andor but I do
think that yeah through action and
through contrast they still reveal his
character and because he is the
character who will persist through all
these events of the show I feel like
there is still ample opportunity to
develop him and to make him somebody
interesting and to slowly Blossom that
sense of belief because I feel like what
this episode helps to illustrate is you
know he comes like you know the The
Hired Gun with a code is a is a Trope
surely and he comes into this with a
certain amount of reluct and he seems
very intent on keeping and honoring just
the deal made no more no less and that's
you know different from the person who
will come in and you know like sell you
a yarn about his you know brother and
his brother's farm and then later on be
like I am only in this for myself truly
like Andor I feel like he puts that out
there but I feel like he also you know
knows the pain of Hope and investing in
people you know you're gonna lose and
probably reset resists uh you know
taking an actual stand up until this
point partly because of those things and
so here it's like as much as he is the
outsider of the group and as much as it
is like I'm the one who's getting paid
to be here you know like I have the
least uh moral ties to this you can
still tell that there is a moral person
with a moral compass within him and so
like when you know skiing is pitching
him this plan he he seems like like
taken aback and kind of upset almost by
the prospect of like really you're gonna
try and pull this you know this
like crook level double cross and so
yeah I feel like you know it says
something about his character and yeah
you don't need a bunch of debate lines
between him and Val she's going to
believe what she's going to believe but
the way he puts it to her just like
think on that all I want yeah is my cut
and and you know what was agreed upon no
more no less and it and it holds
consistent with that and for the rest of
it yeah I think there is a lot of great
just body language and again each of the
different characters you know as they
open up they bring stuff out of Andor
but too I just I loved uh yeah the
immediacy the intensity the way that
they use geography the way that they
really realized like this was such a
physical episode and not just because
it's the most action-packed one and not
just because it's the one where they're
carrying out the mission it is but they
used all the physical elements from the
tribes people to uh the you know
geography and the layout of this Outpost
that they're in and two the way things
go wrong when certain people are able to
do their jobs like the guy up on the
bridge who's like noticing that the
comms are down and something fishy is
going on like I think you count on a lot
of Star Wars things these characters of
the Empire to be these these Imperial
guards and things you know to be lacks
and not very good at their jobs unless
they're the higher up guys and here you
get a way better sense for the actual
like on the ground reality of it and two
I think it's easy to think of oh the
Rebellion they're the good guys and this
is will always be like glorious to some
degree but the operation itself is Harsh
and requires them to do certain things
that aren't heroic and that aren't moral
taking the family hostage and all that
stuff killing that one guy
um and yeah like they draw firm lines
but you know in in a war in a star war
nothing is gonna be easy nothing's gonna
be clean cut and I think this show
really lives there without
you know being too lurid about it
without going like we're being edgy but
without also you know skimping on every
element you know the eye you know kind
of overpinning all this is beautiful
because it's such a cultural thing and
it also leads to dazzling visuals like
everything is just so well motivated
here I feel like yeah it is very well
motivated I think the the way they've
drawn out the the something as simple as
the little details of the way the
soldiers will behave like they feel like
real people in there before there was
always something that felt kind of
tropey about a lot of the the the people
in the Empire you know like I loved like
when the heist is going on before you
get into the room where where the one
guy is shot
um from on the Empire side when they're
in the little corridors they go into the
room the guy's just kind of sitting down
bored and then when the door opens he
like shoots up on his feet there's
something that's very realistic about a
touch like that where I had a I had a
thought that came out of my my head at
the moment of like feel like most of the
time in these movies a guy would just be
standing there kind of just waiting very
Stern doing his job yeah and I like the
realistic Touch of things like that I
kind of feel like they sort of do that
all around with a lot of their
characters or little these little side
characters as well and the way they
imbue culture a lot of the time in here
too like these people of uh that they're
called
so it's called all Donnie they're called
the Donnie yeah so the the Donnies
I don't know what they're saying a lot
of the time but getting to see a lot of
their their rituals their emotional
experience and seeing how effective they
are about these Invaders occupying their
natural land you know and and messing
with their rituals and they have to
they have to go through them in order to
do what they would have been doing nor
like they to proceed normally with their
ritual they have to sort of get approval
from them to make an exchange and all
this yeah yeah no it's [ __ ] and you
you're seeing seeing something as little
as that
is irksome and I I like that they kept
cutting back to that it was almost like
when they're pulling off the rebel when
they're pulling off the rebel heist
mission
part of cutting back to that was making
me go this is like what they're fighting
for right here is the freedom for these
guys to do what they want to do okay you
know so that way we can all have our
freedom and not to live under some type
of Imperial rule in some [ __ ]
situation so I think even cutting to
that was also very effective and also
brought a different kind of layer of a
of emotion throughout
on top of all that I mean it's just a
really cool episode it was it was really
exciting and it was it was pulsating and
you know I is this kind of thing worse
like of course Xander's gonna make it
out alive he's got Rogue one to get to
I would not think about that because I
wasn't invested enough in the actual
team that I was getting worried about
who might die who you know like when
like sometimes it got a little bit
chaotic for me so you saw tarmend I
and I I love that added detail too you
know showing just how messed up it is in
in the ruling of it that you have some
like tarmin who was a former
Stormtrooper and then you have uh
Lieutenant Gorn you know like his
exchange that he has with a commandant
was great you know of you'll be hanged
for this serving with you for seven
years that deserve worse like he's done
some things some Deeds that he regrets
and this is him trying to make up for a
lot of those wrongs
it adds such Nuance to it and I like
that a lot of these characters you don't
need to get this heavy amount of
exposition and in fact with skiing a lot
of that Exposition was a big mislead for
this turn you know which I thought was
interesting because you had some of the
most Exposition out of anyone and a lot
of it was just a a a revelation and
again exploring the gray area of like oh
man I thought it was simple good versus
bad but there's some corruption here too
he's not exactly for the rebels he's not
for the Empire but he could still be a
backstabbing [ __ ]
um there's great stuff all around and
man that the visuals and like the Tie
fighters and everything to do with the
eye uh you know when you're on the
ground level it's so gorgeous to look at
it it feels real like watching what
what's the term for it like with the
Northern Exposure lights and the
Northern Lights the Aurora Borealis yeah
those that something I've always wanted
to witness was rays and it feels like
the heightened level of that it's like
yeah charged up in fiber optic yeah so
it's so full of wonder and I love the
emotion when you're like cutting to the
crowd of the dollies and you have like
even one woman so moved to Tears by that
I thought was gorgeous yeah and then
when you're actually on the Escape Route
it's like exciting intense but also
still maintains looking gorgeous that
was some of the most beautiful imagery
from any of these Star Wars shows and
perhaps Star Wars in general I think
they ever did well and and yeah and I I
feel like things like that and things
like even some of the sound effects like
hearing those TIE fighter blasts go off
it's like you're not hearing them
constantly and so when you do hear them
it's that much more striking and in this
show you've spent so much time in these
dingy places in much more dreary
conditions and then here yeah you have
this beautiful thing that's happening
but that's also yeah you would never
want to fly through and it creates yeah
a fascinating
urgency in the midst of all this and uh
and too just the way in which they they
pepper and color like the how you know
obviously Goran is a more sympathetic
character and you know I don't know
everything about you know where how his
story has unfolded in getting him here
as you know this this piece of the
puzzle of the Rebellion but you know
clearly this is a person who does like
respect at least the Customs these
people have and the guy he's dealing
with the the j-hold character like isn't
cartoonishly nasty about it but he is
just like I I don't care about this
stuff like I think this is kind of
stupid but I have to do it because you
know this is bureaucracy and uh and like
for his kid it's a chore and for the
wife she's just trying to hold things
together and like yeah there's there's
so much happening everywhere and and I
love that in this episode you have the
heist going on and you really feel
the time and the sort of no turning back
of it all because you know having that
bit where Vel is like hesitating and you
know is is
reluctant like can't bring herself to
answer the call and to set the mission
in in motion uh like that affects
everything and they're you know waiting
by the gate uh the four of them and
they're like she should have called by
now you know you you feel the time and
you feel how like even a few minutes can
change everything and that serves to
make the whole layout and all the
different characters feel that much more
present and alive and real so that when
the you know actual Heist is unfolding
like I feel like you're I'm so used to
seeing things where you know something
eventually goes wrong but the team is
well oiled and up to a certain point
everything's going according to plan
whereas here the plan just feels like a
rough checklist of events and and you
know variables will vary and I think
that's a really precious mood to be able
to strike and to still have it feel so
engrossing and interesting and colorful
but also incredibly tense the entire
time too you and so like the Hat's way
off to the direction especially on this
episode yeah I it makes me wonder where
the progression of this series is going
to go because you didn't check them with
cereal at all
and I imagine there's got to be some
type of someone might remember andor's
face they might uh there might be some
type of security camera there that
actually caught his face or something
like that I don't know
um but he's got to come in some way yeah
be like I got to make up for what
happened that was right I gotta go after
Andor
uh I I loved it even the the littlest
touches that they would do would like
comment with the commandant of seeing
his family you know you introduce him as
just something like hey okay I'm putting
the Empire all right yes
screwing them over here we have cost
safe costs on these on these peasants
and then when you check in with the
family you see the family is all right
so when they don't even want to be here
and they're put in danger you're like oh
bummer
um yeah yeah it was it was a nice it was
a nice touch to even humanize that
character to see what motivates him
Beyond just you know like when he's
caught in a situation you I feel like
without having checked in with the
family you might be like writing this
character as just sort of arrogant
pumbas and and just sort of uh resistant
and he might be the one to try to pull
the gun on the people pulling the heist
but here you know when the family's in
danger you see that he actually does
really love them so he's not going to
risk you know this their mission going
wrong or he's not going to try to
sabotage their mission because he's
trying to keep his family alive yeah you
know and I I thought that was excellent
stuff well in the way he even just
passes out from like what a heart attack
or whatever at the end there it's like
there's so many details that they
clearly like took to talk about being
fat that's right man couldn't Buckle
that belt up man now he's got a heart
disease yeah it's a real problem
they're getting fat up there that was a
nice touch of like yeah he's got health
problems yeah and a subtle way of like
pointing that out I thought was great
um yeah just beautiful in scope to
behold to and uh the vowel's center the
the girl Center she was badass yeah she
took charge looks like she's alive I
think she's oh yeah I mean she's the
she's just there still so I wonder if
she's gonna live undercover for six
years that's right she's gonna take it
this whole time now I'm here to replace
uh the trader guy I have orders they can
answer sir to me it doesn't matter
whatever they want you know or they want
to just get away with it because I wear
this uniform they are sheep around here
um yeah this was this was awesome and I
love Lutheran's moment at the end too
that was another great little human
because because you're thinking into the
back of your mind you're like oh is he
gonna go back through and do a little
happy dance but sure enough it is like
the perfect blend of like
of like momentary joy relief
oh there's a there's a lot in there's a
lot of head there's a long road ahead
yeah and there there is a tense
situation because now that the rebel
attack has begun you have characters
like mon mothma he's probably gonna end
up leaving her husband and kid behind
inside the process right never and and
then you have Lutheran and all these
people are you know there's like a lot
of secrecy and double lives so
yeah this is this is awesome because
they made a big impact here this you are
seeing the Catalyst for there's a
rebellion happening and we need to shut
this [ __ ] down it's awesome oh man I
think this is a a wonderful start and it
does enhance
you know the importance of Cassie and
Andor I'm going to go back to the main
character of he was there for the most
pivot the first pivotal
in fact this should have been the movie
I know the first Ripple attack this this
does enhance that first pivotal moment
for the Rebecca for the Rebellion where
people are like there is a rebellion
it does feel so somehow much more like
yeah important than Rogue one did yeah
because it's like we already knew that
what they were doing was gonna succeed
whereas here yeah it's so far removed
and you know there's so much hardship
ahead that it's like yeah now this is
the the spark that lights the fire that
will spread versus like these last few
moments of the first fire yeah you know
well it goes back to that theme there's
that one line and they featured in the
recap uh that
uh Dynamic says about attack from oh
yeah yeah it's better than above or
something yeah yeah something like that
they won't expect it coming from below
or yeah which is what they did here as
opposed to like get ships and blast yeah
yeah one's like you've always got these
like these Rogue Tie fighters flying
over once in a while just to remind you
like oh yeah they've got Skies covered
well I like a good sneaking heist
mission and I think the shootout felt
like one and I've always talked about
this in a previous episode but the
shootout again felt like just instead of
bullets as lasers you know but it still
feels yeah and that realistic nuanced
touch to it but yeah guys what'd you
think about this episode do you like it
as much as us leave your thoughts down
below subscribe click that Bell also uh
thank you to Tops for sponsoring this
video Star Wars Trader card Trader gets
some cards collect them get some cards
on you rock stars also shine them out on
an Andor video they're taking up the
Andor space right now and let's send
this to the pain
yeah
Brandon Benzie Colonel Benzie there you
go that's your Star Wars role you would
be an imperial officer but you would be
a double agent Brendan Benzie because
you know you're here with us we You
Gotta Have a Heart of Gold of some kind
you know you're gonna probably see a lot
of atrocities you're probably going to
be complicit in a lot of ugly nasty
things but when the time comes and it
counts you're gonna do the right thing
and you're gonna do it with gusto my
friend you always hit your Target and
we're glad to have you with us so be
well and uh rebell and uh hit that
notification Bell I assume you did that
because because you're you're subscribed
anyway stay with the patreon and and
we'll we'll catch you soon love you
foreign
[Music]